hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to minecraft it's been
a bit of an odd
um it's been a bit of an odd one but i
now have everything i need
to make everything i have that's good oh
and i put the
i put the bookshelves in with the the
thing so i've got max out
enchanting i've got max enchanting i
don't know if
a triple layer is gonna work i don't
think
but it couldn't hurt i had extra which
is something i never thought that i'd
have
oh why anyway so i'm gonna make this
redstone work
and all i need to do to do that is put
in
more powered rails and then finally
i can declare myself a redstone expert
and then i will be making a fully
functioning game boy within minecraft
within the hour okay finally this
is going to work
yes yes yes go go go
yes yes
hi sup i did it
i've done it i now have my functioning
my functioning what are you doing
what are you doing anyway i'll harvest
my wheat
because i'm a good farmer cows
it's time again cows
oh i can wield wheat
and it works okay well that's good
that's great okay not what i'm here for
all of this preparation all of this
skill building
all of this get away from my cauldron
you
pooping freak you need to not
do that just don't do that okay i'm
gonna put lava in here
ah i didn't mean to do that oh my god
oh my god oh my god
you can't put lava in there oh he's dead
oh he's died oh he's dead
oh my god i'm dying
oh i don't know where your friend went
he's weird uh
very strange really weird
i don't know what happened just vanished
so weird
i think did you just cry did i see
you something dropped did you spit or
cry did you spit on me
i might show you where your friend is
after all if you spat on me
you're about to find out i don't think
you're at all the answer
anyway um yeah so we got a rail uh which
will lead down but you know all of that
is secondary because what we're really
about here
i know you're listening intensely sir
and i appreciate that
oh my god i am going to destroy
him oh also i traded with the dude for
leather for an emerald
i got one emerald
going to destroy this is he an arthropod
i will annihilate him
okay i will i will annihilate you i will
annihilate you
i will annihilate you anyway what i'm
gonna do is it's
oh my god i'm gonna annihilate you it's
time to go back to the nether
is that okay oh my god
it's not oh my god anyway i'm gonna go
there's a big lake of lava down below
and i'm going to go find it go
did you just
what is wrong with you
it's okay it's fine you can't bother me
here
so i am going to get obsidian
and then i wish i had a better pickaxe
i could have a better pickaxe i've got
the enchanting
i'm level 30 i could have the ultimate
pickaxe
i could have the greatest pickaxe
i made ah and it's unchanted on enchant
it's unchanted and i've got all these
bookshelves
and i know i don't have lapis yeah
now i know that this is going to be the
best pickaxe that ever existed
because i said so silk touch
what does that mean efficiency 3 and
silk touch
that sounds good that sounds real good
some people say that i also have a silk
and touch
[Applause]
i really don't know why i have wheat in
my offhand but whatever it's fine
it doesn't seem to be going much faster
i guess it's still kind of slow no i'm
still using the older
one
much better so good
yes yes
yes yes yes yes okay
this is great this is really good stuff
they're still they're probably still
yeah there's a lot of underneath
i don't know if there'll be another
layer
oh my god oh no no not like this no my
god oh my god oh my god oh my god what
do i do uh ladder ladder ladder get me
out of here ladder
lighter lighter louder louder oh my god
ladder oh my god oh my god put something
beneath me
what's happening water water oh my god
oh my god oh my god oh my god
okay i'm fine everything's good
it's all good
okay that's ten that's all i need
oh oh what the hell
is that what silk touch does okay well i
mean that's not
helpful is that helpful i have no idea
whatever probably helpful for something
but i don't know
okay back up we
i literally had all of my enchanted
stuff on me in a pit of lava
i would have lost everything absolutely
everything
i would have lost everything but i
didn't and that's what matters
i didn't lose everything and so long as
i don't lose everything everything will
be okay i
see that creeper trying to creep on me
[Music]
there you go cow there you go hey eat up
it up beat up eat him up
and grow big and strong okay good that's
enough for you
don't be greedy you can get addicted to
the wheat
okay so now we got uh this we just need
flint and iron to make
the thing we got that we made two
what oh i guess we made two let's make
it right here
with dirt accents
it will be perfect
it's perfect schwab
i'm gonna go and i am gonna kill some
enderman
i'm gonna kill them dead they're gonna
die
and i will have killed them i have my
armor i have
my hope i have my torches i've got
everything i need
i'm gonna find him and i'm gonna kill
him
i found him oh it's the same one right
right of course of course
all right either way i'm back i'm ready
this time
it's personal oh don't even try don't
even try you can't even try
you won't even try you yeah fight me
fight me fight me
fight me fight all of me oh that's a lot
more than i thought that would be
okay all right this is fine it's fine
it's fine
oh you're tough but not tough enough
cry all you want all of you deserve to
die
evil demon pigs
[Music]
i need your experience oh and your gold
sword that doesn't do much damage that's
very pathetic
okay so there was a lot of endermen that
were down
in the mushroom nether biome i don't
know what that is
oh i also needed like some something
here
this stuff blackstone did i need
blackstone
i can't remember why but i remember
something i needed some material
is my ladder still there oh it is it's
been so long since i've been back here
it's almost like another lifetime but
i've grown i've become more powerful
since then
nothing can stand in my way there you
are now
you shall die you cannot hurt me anymore
pathetic pitiful
i shall destroy you all
pitiful you too youtube get over here
yeah why don't you all
you all pile on me huh pile on me
oh don't pile on me wait don't don't
pile on me so much
okay ow actually out out ow ow ow
actually out out
wait wait wait wait wait oh no no not
now
not now what are you doing yeah you oh
yeah you
oh were you oh oh what are you doing
what do you think you're doing oh you
think
you can fight me no no these must be the
weaklings that i knocked off the
the edge or something or maybe they fell
and got hurt but i'm so strong and i
swoped into them
with my mighty swoopers oh hey you stuck
in there
you stuck in a little hole boink too bad
for you
pathetic where'd you go ow
oh hello where'd you go there's tons of
them
ow ow you hurt a lot
am i getting anything oh i am okay i am
getting things from them good excellent
very excellent all right i gotta get
over to you actually i don't i just need
to look at you
right i just need to look at you look at
your big stupid faces
yeah i poured over here whoa hello
hello fine be that way i'll go i'll go
over to you
well i'm coming over there i'm gonna
fight you
how do i get over there just you wait
i'm coming over there
i'm gonna get you i'm gonna get you to
get dead
you're gonna be gone hold on i just need
to get enough material to get over to
you and then you're gonna be
gone then you're gonna be dead and then
i'm gonna fight you
and then you're gonna be gone all right
time to show you who is
boss it's me surprise one second gotta
get down
safely before i go get you maybe
actually i'm just gonna build a bridge
over to you
yeah how do you think about that now
that i know you can just crouch and be
safe
you can't fall off if you're crouching
now that i know that i'm
coming to get you oh you're scared now
i'm coming to get you
oh yeah you better cry cause you wait oh
yeah you're done now just wait a moment
all right now you're done for don't
where'd you go i'm gonna fight you now
oh
don't go in the lava i need your pearl
where'd you go
stop being so shaky stop it stop there
we go
thank you for nothing i'm really bad at
smack talking uh you hey come over here
it's got a saddle on his head can i ride
that thing can i ride that is that
something i can ride
weird all right whatever not what i'm
here for i'm coming for you
ah how about thee
nerd okay enderman you gonna do
something about your temper tantrum
loser nerd wow hey you're nerd nerd
that's what i thought nerd comedy i'm
coming for you
coming i'm coming you're gonna get it
he's trembling with fear got him
well that wasn't nearly as productive as
i thought it was gonna be
i killed like 10 of them i only got
three pearls oh hey
bud at least they respawn am i just
gonna have to farm these guys
is that really what i'm gonna do where'd
you go there you go don't think about it
i got another pearl
how many do i need i have no idea i
don't know how to use them i know there
to get to the end but
come at me come at me
you come to me come to me get over here
yeah yeah take my stairs i made those
just so you could come over here and get
wrecked i can't punch you from all the
way over there
miss me pathetic
well i got five i guess so something
gave me one i don't know how many i need
but
five is a good start i'm sure there's
more secrets in this new nether
that i have yet to explore but i'm far
too dumb to discern
what they are so this was a good
adventure i really showed everyone who
is the boss over here
and the answer is me are you dudes
missed you were point blank and you
missed pathetic
pitiful so what else is here oh blue
fire blue fire is interesting at least
that's something different
how do i get away traversing the nether
is a real pain
it is quite annoying a lot of scary
possible
death drops you know what i mean a lot
of just unknowable
angles and whatnot oh there's a layer up
oh there's so much up
i didn't know that oh is this the stuff
i need
oh my god
i'm fine this is the episode of heart
attacks
okay i got the soul soil
i can make whatever with that
i really didn't enjoy that die die
die die die die
i also still don't know what necessarily
to do with quartz but it does get of
experience
did i bring my shield i did not what is
this thing the magma cream
i don't know what the magma cream is
about
whoa hey where whoa whoa
who did that there's no one there
okay sure that's a
it's ghost invisible gas i'm sure that
exists
okay okay okay hey yeah yeah
sneak attack i really should be leaving
a trail for myself to get back but
i won't do that because it's too late is
it is it worth it like making a base in
the nether can you even make a
bed and oh that's a drop well it's not
that bad of a drop actually
that's okay yep out
is it even worth making a base in the
nether can you sleep here there's no
real day night so i guess not
he's got pants he's got pants he's too
dangerous to let live
i took his pants oh whoa what is that
about
oh what is that it's like a red mushroom
forest
strange no no no no no
oh tiny pig i hate it these guys are
real maybe i shouldn't have started
killing these guys because they're
they're they are a problem in a swarm
and the little ones are terrifying oh no
you're a little not zombie one oh yeah
run
yeah run away you can't run not from me
[Music]
got him maybe i shouldn't be so happy
about killing the equivalent of a
pigman child
what the hell
okay okay i did
i did it i did it thank you for
recognizing my achievement i was
wondering when i was gonna get that
sitting here like um excuse me i've done
it
the thing that you already know give me
my reward
and then it did so finally where do i go
okay i've man this just goes on forever
um
oh you oh you go slow on that skeleton
what are you doing here skellington
there's no skeletons down here all right
i'm not gonna hit you
why are there skeletons here what is
that about weird
oh there's faces on it
well that's a little weird oh they're
different
soul soil and soil sand soul sand oh
that's weird
oh this whole place is different oh
weird
you know what i'm i'm going home i don't
like this place this place stinks
plays real dumb okay how'd i've done it
i've i'm lost
um uh uh
oh no hey hole
oh i don't know oh i don't know what's
with this thing
what is that all about i don't know this
whole place is weird
yeah what is this bone
oh this is bone oh it's all it's just
bone
handy i got i can make my plants grow i
guess
handy oh yeah oh yeah
oh hell yeah all right so i i gotta get
out of here i i
i want to go home i just want to go home
please i would like to go home
[Music]
oh i see my uh oh that's so far uh okay
great
i really did it this time
okay so somewhere over here oh
please don't and i'm lost again
great oh no i'm never gonna get out i'm
trapped in the nether
i didn't plan this i didn't plan this at
all oh
no oh oh no where am i
where am i oh where am i oh where
am i oh i don't know where i am
oh no oh i have no idea where i am
am i too high up did i go too up am i
like
a a level two high i saw my torches
before where were they
oh no no that's wrong this is wrong
this is wrong oh that's wrong oh where
is this
oh where is this can i start if i have
this fall yes
i don't know no oh my god i almost
didn't
i'm fine i'm a lost little baby
help help me help
none of this is familiar help
where did i go i'm too high how did i
get this high up
okay so i need to go down i think ow
oh the no i can't i can't do that but it
looks like
if i go far enough in it'll be okay if i
drop down
probably here this will be fine this is
gonna be fine it's gonna be fine i trust
i trust i trust i trust i trust i trust
uh i'm fine okay this looks better
where's my freaking oh
no no
there it is there it is okay there it is
so i must uh either
because i went up thinking that like
yeah i dropped uh still burns
you know what actually i'm just gonna go
over here and i'm gonna i'm gonna
build up i'm gonna build up hi you
you don't have a saddle on you you also
are very ugly
i'm sorry to say but it's true if i just
build straight up right here
okay good crouching
easy
safe okay there's my torch that means i
must have come this way
there's another torch over there yes yes
yes i'm going home i won't be a lost
little boy anymore
i'm a man i'm a big strong
man i'm a bit where
torch but must be up
it must be above me i must have fallen
down
i have a tendency to do that it's a
great strategy
almost infallible okay this must be the
correct level
then i must this way must be where my
portal is there's a ladder
i spa oh my god oh my god
oh my god i don't remember building this
did i build this i didn't build this
but i'm here and i'm going home
gast you stay away from me you nightmare
monster
don't oh oh
oh wow wow i'm burning help
help please go home me home please
one home for me please
all right oh god dang
dang it this is not my home
damn oh god i fell
damn you okay damn you
well i've done it really geniused my way
through this one
now all i have to do is get home
almost too easy alexian play some uh oh
this is a great opportunity i i had i
asked for this
uh before lixian play the epic journey
music that i told you about in the
episode that didn't get recorded
you know the one when i told you to play
the epic journeying music that was gonna
take me across the mountaintops so that
i could reach a new land and be safe
you remember the one right play the
exact one that we were talking about
before when i was talking to you and i
didn't get the episode to you
you remember it right right good thank
you
play it now
that's not the song
play the song you remember the one
so play it
wrong one you get it wrong again
and i'll cut your hair off permanently
is that the right one
oh you don't want to be wrong
are you sure
go with it if you're confident
oh hey that's the right one oh thank you
oh cool
[Music]
and i'm back home
yay wahoo okay
all right that'll do it for this episode
i got a lot of experience and a lot of
weird goodies but
it's real nice just being home
and a lot of bones too so that's extra
cool so thank you everybody so much for
watching
we're getting closer to getting to our
destination
of the end and then beating the ender
dragon
it's just one step at a time i don't
know how many pearls i need
anyway thank you and as always i will
see you
in the next video bye-bye
[Music]
you